hey youtubers is Charlie happy Star Wars
day may the 4th be with you so Vanity
Fair did a behind-the-scenes shoot with
the cast and revealed who some of the
mystery people are some of the really
big characters so there's gonna be a
breakdown of that just going down to
list the biggest reveal is that Adam
driver is kylo Ren the Dark Jedi in the
mask the last trailer revealed that he
was a big player in the Empire he's
leading around stormtroopers during Star
Wars Celebration they confirmed that the
Empire is now called the first-order
this is their symbol it's just a slight
modification of the traditional Imperial
crest the rebellion is now known as the
resistance as much as the new films are
intended to honor the classic trilogy
you know thematically and visually we're
gonna see a lot of new places a lot of
new characters the chrome trooper
captain phasma was revealed as
Gwendoline Christie from Game of Thrones
Peter Mayhew actually dropped that one
on Twitter wookie roar until we get a
little more information about our
character I'm just gonna think of her as
like a twisted evil version of Brienne
of Tarth darkest timeline Brienne she
didn't appear on screen with kylo Ren in
the trailer but they're both working for
the first-order somatically you can see
how kylo Ren kind of represents the
Darth Vader of the film Gwendoline
Christie is the new addition she's just
like one of many new badass females
they're introducing to the Star Wars
universe one of my favorite Star Wars
jokes was that Princess Leia was like
the only woman in the galaxy we don't
know that's not true because we saw
Jabba's palace but for most of the
film's yeah she was the only woman on
screen the next big WTF reveal is that
Lupita and yonkos character is
motion-capture her name is mask anata we
don't know what she's gonna look like we
just saw the motion capture BTS of her
the rumors right now are that she's
playing a pirate but I think based on
the types of characters that Lupita has
played in the past she'll be good even
if she's not part of the resistance one
of the big goals of episode 7 is
transitioning from the classic cast
classic setting to new characters new
setting so it makes sense that they
would bring in a new Chewbacca type
friendly character to go on adventures
with the new cast hopefully that means
that Chewbacca is not going to die but
if the Falcon is going to pass ownership
into new hands sometime during the new
trilogy then it makes sense to have like
a new Chewbacca type character in the
cast just like a really big badass
looking alien in case you didn't hear
too
lupita is actually gonna be in the the
motion capture like the live-action
jungle book movie she'll be playing
Mowgli's Wolfmother
so you can see how she's cast in these
really big movies as you know somewhat
more benevolent characters fierce but
benevolent they also they typically they
don't do this level of motion capture if
they're not going to radically alter an
actor's face like think Manu Bennett as
azog the Defiler or Benedict
Cumberbatch's Smaug vastly different
alien faces and I'm just like so excited
to see what it looks like my guess is is
that they're still deep in CG on the
movie usually it's easier to shoot the
live-action stuff for movies like this
than it is to do post-production just
there's like so many visual effects they
have to lay in even though they built a
ton of really awesome sets like the
Millennium Falcon here
there's gonna be a shitload of CG the
Millennium Falcon pictures are really
awesome too it gives you an idea of how
they tweaked a lot of the backgrounds so
you look in the background here and yeah
obviously it's a new set based on the
classic Falcon said but they redid all
the backgrounds and lit it in a slightly
different way at least for this photo
shoot so you can see how much more
complex the set has gotten it's just now
that we're living in the era of HD it's
like you can see what's going on way off
in the distance we're in like an old
film that wasn't as big of a priority
like micro details does it be like if
Apple rebuilt the Apple 2 computer using
modern components but it still looked
like the classic design we already know
way more about the rest of the cast that
appeared in the shoot so this is mostly
a Millennium Falcon shoot so you have
Finn Rey Han Solo and Chewie they also
shot with Poe Dameron too next to his
x-wing he's obviously part of the
resistance the tease is is that at some
point Poe dameron's character is going
to cross paths with finn and rey finn
and rey as you can expect are you know
kind of meant to thematically replace
certain original trilogy cast characters
just looking at their costumes you can
guess you know rey is really like the
new Princess Leia finn is the new luke
skywalker and poe dameron is the new Han
Solo even though it's just a rumor I do
think that Rey is the daughter of Han
and Leia so I think she and Finn will
both be new jedi characters eventually
I'm really crossing my fingers that they
open the film the same way too like they
open it with the droids just like they
opened episode 4 George Lucas was pretty
honest about stealing
that bit from akira kurosawa samurai
films like it's right out of hidden
fortress you open the film with the
least important characters and use them
to introduce the audience to the world
of the film to the story and the main
characters once you meet the main
characters the film switches perspective
and starts following them so I'm hoping
that we get kind of the same thing we
have the bb-8 droid here so I'm actually
I'm gonna guess that this will take the
place of the c-3po r2
in Episode four you see it roll into
frame it'll introduce us to the world of
jakku that's the planet that they're on
right here then we'll meet the main cast
and it'll start following them but the
bb-8 droid is a really important
addition to the cast there's just
there's no person inside of it operating
it like there was with artoo and c3po so
here's my big question for you guys you
know which of these new cast members are
you most excited to see you know what do
you think about the chrome trooper
Gwendoline Christie what do you think
about atom drivers character they
actually they showed off his lightsaber
at Star Wars Celebration never has there
been so much conversation about the
design of a lightsaber then the cross
saber as you can see it looks like it's
cobbled together it kind of gives you an
idea of where his characters out in the
film like he's kind of learning about
the force on his own he has no master so
he has an imperfect understanding of
lightsaber mechanics so he you know he
builds this using secondhand items will
call this saber a work in progress when
big character that I think that he's
going to interact with a certain point
is Andy Serkis
they haven't confirmed who he is but the
rumor is is that he's playing a
motion-capture character that predates
the original trilogy this is Star Wars
so remember there's always a guy behind
the guy Darth Vader had the Emperor Andy
Serkis is rumored to be the guy behind
the Emperor the guy behind the guy
behind the guy just based on the
conversations that I see going on we
might not see his character till episode
8 like he might only barely be mentioned
in episode 7 which was kind of the case
with episodes 4 & 5 like you just get a
tease for the Emperor in a new hope and
then Empire Strikes Back BAM you meet
him full on it just hammers home the
idea that you know they're doing a lot
of new things but they're still visually
anthem Attica Lee honoring the original
trilogy you guys let me know what you
think though do you like the idea that
there is someone older and more powerful
than the Emperor that's just been
watching all this go on I'm also
excited to see Luke Skywalker take on
more of an obi-wan Kenobi role you don't
really get a sense of it from the
trailers they've shown but it seems like
he's kind of gone off the reservation a
little bit got into like full-on hermit
mode so just because it's Star Wars day
you guys can click here to watch the
trailer again like three or four more
times and you can click here for last
night's Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five may the fourth be with you